[Music]
how does one define simplicity very good
question to me it is just a distilled
thought something that registers quickly
doesn't require a lot of explanation
seems intuitively obvious that kind of a
thing and I think a lot of businesses
out there tend to put things in terms
that require more more thought study or
whatever and I think what made Steve
Jobs such a genius was that he had this
belief in the power of simplicity and he
wanted to ensure that his products
embodied that and the way the company
communicated with people embodied that
so I think simplicity is this thing it's
a concept really that gets applied to so
many different things it's not just oh
look it's a simple product it's it's the
whole structure of the organization is
the belief system all that stuff is
based on this idea that that human
beings have a a built-in desire for
simpler things we just don't like to
labor over complex issues and when
someone has something to to share with
us whether it's a product of service or
whatever that the people who who really
understand that simplicity is a very
powerful thing those are the people who
establish an emotional connection with
their customers which is something that
Apple is very very good at doing I do
think that simplicity is one of the
hardest things you can do and it is
deceptive in that way because it looks
simple the way I like to put it is that
there is no such thing as simplicity
there is only the perception of
simplicity that
every simple thing we see in this world
whether it's an iPhone obviously years
where the research goes into making the
little things that make an iPhone but
you could look at a simple website and
we all know we who create such things
know that this beautifully simple site
that you've you've built could have been
the result of of weeks or months of
anguish debate and differences of
opinion and arguments and whatever and
you end up with something that's simple
so what's really important is the
perception of simplicity that if if
someone walks away from the experience
and feels that it was simple that's you
know mission accomplished but I think
getting there is really really hard
it requires all that commitment and
energy it it doesn't come easily I guess
that's the point but when you do get
there it becomes very very worth it in
fact there's a great Steve Jobs quote
it's always about Steve Jobs isn't it
what he said that it takes a lot of hard
work to make something simple but it's
worth it in the end because once you get
there you can move mountains and I think
those are great words to live by but he
understood that that was the the the
challenge for Apple was to take really
cool products and really cool
capabilities and put them in a in a form
that that people could so easily relate
to and and take advantage of without
thick manuals and that kind of a thing
so that's the real work is making great
things simple the big question is how do
you do it where does simplicity come
from and that's a question I hear all
the time and you know I have some humble
suggestions on that topic I think
because simple is such a simple thing it
comes along with some simple advice and
I think that one of the most important
things you can do is simply step back
and look at your what you're doing
through the eyes of the customer
I believe that that was Steve Jobs
amazing strength that he looked at this
experience that Apple was creating and
he looked at it with a super critical
eye what would he think as a customer I
think that a lot of company leaders
don't do that as well as Steve and I
think you can criticize your own
products and services and your website
and all that stuff you can excuse your
own lapses by saying yeah well we did
the best we could because we had these
certain issues and that's how we dealt
with it but that's the difference
between you know a regular person and a
Steve Jobs kind of a person Steve was
just I'm sorry no compromise is allowed
and if you suggest to me that we're
going to compromise you know your future
here is probably not very good he
believed that the user experience was
all important and so I always tell
people you know the best place to start
for me is to just be the customer and
look at every part of the customer
experience from the very first ad they
might see to the website to what the
retail experience is like you know how
hard it is to order when you get the
product what does it feel like to open
it up and and start experiencing it and
and the then of course the design of the
product the interface when you need help
what you know how easy is it to get
support the whole bit so you create this
experience that is simple for people and
you know fails to to confuse them in a
very very good way so you know you look
at all the choices some people provide
to their customers you know with all the
best intentions you might go to a
website and there are 20 different
products to choose from whereas a
company that really believes in
simplicity might say here are three and
we've thought it all out there are three
kinds of people here there's you know
the small medium and large or whatever
it is that make it easy for you to make
a decision rather than then you know
force you to think too hard and then
wonder after you made the purchase
whether you might have made a big
take that kind of a thing so I think
Apple again has been very good at doing
that kind of a thing so it's customers
go away feeling pretty confident that
they got the right thing and they enjoy
the experience but all along the way all
these decisions that must be made need
to be looked at with a kind of brutal
bit of you know self analysis that is
the experience so good that you would
actually tell your friends about it and
say you got a look at this thing with me
I love this thing and you're gonna like
it too or is it just kind of like okay
and you know I'd buy it and then you
know I'm not sure if I'd tell anyone
about it but that's you know it worked
for me that kind of a thing and I think
in the world of Steve Jobs it was always
about make the experience like amazingly
good and I and too many people are
willing to compromise that away
simplicity requires that kind of that
that brutal assessment of what is really
really good versus what's good enough
and what's good enough isn't good enough
it's got to be really really good okay
so you're mr. simplicity what about your
personal life how simple is that
and the answer is not at all really and
I'm working on it but I think simplicity
is something that works in business and
it should work in your personal life as
well and it's it's a gratifying way to
live and work I think there's something
very satisfying about having this kind
of space in your life and the order and
the lack of clutter and and the firm
direction but you know life is
complicated and that's and it's because
life is complicated that simplicity
stands out so we got to take the good
with the bad you know we live in this
complicated world but that actually
gives us an opportunity to be more
noticed by being simple so whether it's
business or personal simplicity has that
kind of power
[Music]